NARRATOR: Spider-Man has always
been amazing and spectacular.
But it took a mind swap with
one of his greatest enemies
to make him--
Superior in every
way, superior strength,
superior intellect,
superior skills.
NARRATOR: And a
superior ego, yeesh.
Get ready to learn
the full story of how
Otto Octavius became
the Superior Spider-Man,
on Marvel's Long Story Short.
DOCTOR OCTOPUS: Right
in the tentacles.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Doctor Octopus
was a super-scientist
who became a supervillain
after one of his experiments
went horribly wrong.
Um, mind narrowing that down?
That could be a
lot of my villains.
Dolt, you know he's
talking about me.
When my amazing mechanical
limbs fused to my spine,
I became the greatest
criminal mastermind
in New York City And I-
Why don't you let the
narrator do his job, Doc?
NARRATOR: Thanks, Spidey.
I got you.
NARRATOR: Spider-Man spent years
foiling the Doc's evil schemes
and fighting him, mostly
on subways and bridges.
It's where I do my best work.
NARRATOR: But years
of fights took a toll
on the Doc's very human body.
And he did what any mad
scientist approaching
death's door would do.
Accept the inevitable and
make amends with all those
he had wronged?
NARRATOR: Nope, switch brains
with his greatest enemy.
[SIZZLING AND YELLING]
Doctor Octopus was now in
Spider-Man's body with access
to all of his powers.
And I shall use
them to conquer.
NARRATOR: But he
was also empowered
with Spider-Man's conscience.
You ain't getting rid
of me that easy, Doc.
Oh, pooh, being bad
doesn't feel fun anymore.
NARRATOR: And so,
in that moment,
Doctor Octopus vowed
to become the hero he
could never be in his own life.
He would become--
The Superior Spider-Man, for
with great power, there must
also come great responsibility.
Now you're stealing
my lines too?
NARRATOR: For several
months, Otto Octavius
patrolled the streets
of NYC as Spider-Man.
And for an only recently
reformed supervillain,
he did a lot of good.
He stopped villains
like the Vulture--
Too easy.
NARRATOR: The Sinister Six--
There's actually some
appeal to this hero thing.
NARRATOR: --and
the Spider-Slayer.
Perhaps this is
my true calling.
NARRATOR: He even gained some
unlikely fans in the process.
I don't know what it is.
But there's something I like
about you now, Web-head.
[HMPH]
You all make it
sound like he was
a better Spider-Man than me.
And a better Peter Parker.
I spend more time with
Aunt May and moved
in with my new girlfriend.
What's up, Slick?
And I went back to
school to get my doctorate.
You had time for that?
It's called
multitasking, Peter.
Look into it.
NARRATOR: In a lot
of ways, he really
was the Superior Spider-Man.
Come one, narrator.
How about a little
back up, here?
NARRATOR: Well, he also did
some very non-Spider-Man things,
like open up a secret lair
off the coast of Manhattan
and cover the city in an
army of robot spiders.
I knew it.
Well, old evil
habits to die hard.
NARRATOR: But with
the Spider-Bots
patrolling the entire city,
overall crime did go way down.
Unfortunately, the
Green Goblin hacked
the Spider-Bots, allowing
Goblin-related crime
to go way up.
[SIGH]
Eventually, Norman
Osborn was able to take
full control of the
Spider-Bots and used
them to take over the city.
And I stole your
girlfriend, Spider-Man.
NARRATOR: Knowing
that only the real
Spider-Man could save the
day, Doctor Octopus realized--
I must give Peter Parker
control of his body back,
for he is the
Superior Spider-Man.
[SIZZLING AND YELLING]
I'm back.
NARRATOR: And now
you know the truth
behind the Superior
Spider-Man, thanks
to Marvel's Long Story Short.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I still like the
other guy better.
[MUSIC PLAYING]